In order to solve this problem, we need to first make a key observation.
Imagine that we have a block here that's suspended by four springs.
Now we know that in order to calculate the net force on this block,
we have to add up all of the forces contributed by each of these springs,
which is going to be four times the contribution of one spring.
But it also turns out that we can actually imagine all four of these springs
being replaced by just one single spring with a spring constant of 4K.
It turns out that springs when put in parallel like this, you can just add up their spring constants
and treated as one common spring which is a pretty nifty trick.
Now that we know this fact, we can actually just imagine all four of these springs
on the bottom of the car as just being one big spring with spring constant 4K
and now we're ready to solve for the period of oscillations.
We learned in the unit that the period of springs oscillation
is equal to 2π times the square root of the mass of the thing oscillating over the spring constant K.
In this problem; however, this K is actually not the same as this K.
Since this equation only applies to a block on one spring,
we can immediately it to a block on four springs but as we just argued,
these four springs are actually equivalent to one spring with a spring constant of 4K,
so we can actually replace this K with 4K and now we can use this equation.
And plugging in our numbers here, we find that the period of the oscillation of the car
on the spring is equal to 0.44 seconds.